actually really good friends Mark just
went to go work for Harper you've had a
rough couple days since the last time I
saw you yes I have been markline bit
what have you done tell me what you've
done for the last 48 hours well for SARS
Mark come about the beautiful outfit
that you bought me I found this
beautiful leather jacket and it
literally says cool wear on it the label
is cool wear it's really cool show it
off cuz I found it in the dumpster it
was just standing there you've trashed
the dress I got you huh you've trashed
the dress I got you I'm sorry Mark I
didn't know we have to return the sample
you're
highness sorry Mom sorry God you're
always so critical of me I because you
genuinely like me if I'm just genuinely
irritating cuz I don't watch my
interviews I'm just like who the [__] is
that who is that person you
know I'm definitely irritating you're
irritating and you're endearing at the
same
[Music]
time
nothing so yeah I I don't think your
problem is a drug problem at all it's
not a drug problem I say all I think
your problem is a self- Lov problem I
love myself Mar give me a job I love
myself I'm the I'm a goddess there's
only one
Rebecca there is only one Rebeca that's
there's only one Rebecca there will
never be another
Rebecca Rebecca o
witch row I'm the
row I'm
a I'm
a I'm a [__] gentle
man gentleman you know that who did that
um what was that that that rides the
donkey
or that that North Korean
one
uham style
Mark I have like 50 million views I got
to take you to the doctor to get your
ear fixed I know I'm being loud
Mark and to hear no your finger stuck in
your ears just because I keep having to
dig through the [__] that's in my ear
[__] you don't know my
life you don't know my pain and my
suffering I don't I'm sorry it doesn't
look good on
camera but you have no saying what goes
in these videos I don't I have quite a
huge following you know I made you a
star no no I didn't but they have up JY
Cas
yeah M good words of a TV show book deal
with
CBS but whatever you're picking your ear
and your nose we're in talks Mark I'm in
talks with CBS your ear and your feet at
the same time because Mark if you one
comment in our interview is what my feet
hurt and my ears hurt I my feet that I
keep getting tar on them because my
barefoot walking because something
happened you when I was a kid that's why
I'm a Wich now and the ear things
infection I have I always told you about
Mark you'll see one to a doctor but you
never do talk about it all the time in
these videos No we're going to take you
the feet and the ears you've got to
stick around Mark like we agree to take
you to some place hotel or show up like
at times I'm here Mark give me a call
sometime Mark actually take my
anytime I get a phone you give me your
number you don't ask me to call you so I
was like whatever maybe he just there
not that guy i' never had to call you
cuz I on a phone for in five
days through a p more than we we both
know you can't hold on to a phone for
longer than yeah Mark I'm a rich [__]
I'm I throw my phones when I'm drunk I
like throw my phones at the wall throw
my phones at
people I like to give people phones the
other day you me like $100 right all I
did was I spent $10 on us $10 on pack
cigarettes and then I ran around here
giving out money like candy because I
haven't seen you in so long I was like
money you know I oh children you give
away the money I give you sometimes I I
I like sugar mom people tens out here
cuz don't do interview I cuz they're sh
or whatever but they're like buming out
here like you know that one guy what's
his name cookie or Sea Biscuit or one
guy who hangs out I can't remember his
name he a weird name the black guy with
a dads the young one he's a
dog you might not know him but he's
always like chilling with Cory out right
outside your studio
but he's a really love gu like ever
since he's seen me never like a straight
gu just been so chill he's like hey
what's up I'm like what the [__] thank
you he like oh wow you're so amazing
like hey like whoa weird so you know
like every time he pay me I always sh
him 10 or 20 bucks and after doesn't
interviews he's just like like he's like
running off do something else I'll be
like I'll be sitting down here and he's
like he's like my man slave you know
what I he's so sweet like here can go
across the street so yes he's $ are are
you enjoying this life I'm not Mark I'm
Bor as [__] well I mean but get me a
job I try to make that apparent you
think I love living out here that's my
sick Mark it's not the most unfortunate
circumstan in order for an employer to
like Mark I have to have anation stop
telling me to not be a
diva Diva behaviors what get you a job
in this industry and your a [__] ing
sish my ass your dinosaur A's hisry you
don't know what modern society is like
be cool if be different edgy have 20
piercings in your [__] face and I
[__] both the pope you're you're edgy
yes for sure I'm not edgy I'm not edgy
enough why cuz I have no life I'm a
loser I'm a loser baby so I don't check
tell me oh
so I'm a loser
baby can't believe want want to Grand
over Connie cuz
back I'm a Scientologist con put so much
work like into his work he's obsessed
with his work he's such an artist I met
him I met him once ironically uh after
his show a week after his show he did
like a a celebration relaunch at a place
called p in New York and I was there
this when I first met them like second
time I met they always like at Society
events it's really easy you get to meet
them like New York
socities but they're just like not in
the press a lot good for them
imine after that like all that work you
need a shower a couple days of sleep and
a
doctor yes okay Mr the C of that Lobo it
is you SE that movie s last summer
Elizabeth Taylor Katherine heurn weird
Duo but like very iconic I think it's
one of the most prominent films of that
period of time cuz Tennesse Williams who
was gay at the time openly gay not a
common thing wrote it and the main
character ironically so the man is enjy
know for most of the film but it is
believed that the reason that that
Elizabeth Taylor's character is since
the insane asylum that she is out by her
mothers because she called her she told
her mother that her brother was gay just
kissing him on and she called her insane
and sent her to an insane see times like
that drama going on you figure out later
in the movie that apparently he has
already died and was eaten very weirdly
by a group of like 200 accountable
orphans after trying to give them change
outside the restaurant it's a really
weird movie you only get a movie like
that RKO pictures in the '
50s Just Happening like I start watching
modern F the other day I was just really
confused I'm like I got the the sardonic
humor about like or the office I'm like
oh you're doing a [__] chore witty or
a Tor you know what I mean it's like hey
John you're underwear
showing here's a [__] Emmy the only
show that did worplace comedy right is
um 30 Rock 30 Rock was like very acutely
done where it was a good mix of like
seric writer room stuff and like the div
Behavior but it's still too like
commercial there always has to be a
running dog on a s home like with drama
shows you know what I mean it's like
it's like a recurring storyline you know
what I mean oh someone was dating
someone like cool your turtle head is
poking up oh I'm sorry we got a turtle
head my turtle neck well it's a turtle
turtle neck I can buy myself flowers
I'd like to thank better help for being
a sponsor of today's video I think a lot
of my viewers are going through things
just like we all are whether you're a
viewer or not of this channel I think
everybody goes through something and
whether it's depression or anxiety or
you're just going through a tough period
of your life talking with a professional
can be really helpful you know
personally I go through just the stress
of talking to so many people that are
going through tough times tough tough
stories is hard on me and and talking
with a therapist is is really helpful so
I I just started doing that recently
it's been really great for me I'm I'm a
huge fan of therapy and with better help
you can have your therapy session as a
phone call or a video session or even
messaging if you prefer whatever is most
comfortable for you I did mine as as
video which is great it's it's just like
being in their office but you're doing
it from the comfort of your own
home and my better help therapist has
been wonderful right right from the
GetGo he he kind of figured out what my
what my deal is and was really helpful
and what's great about about better help
is you get paired with a therapist
you're matched within 48 hours in most
cases if you're just not feeling it with
your therapist you can try another one
or you can try as many times as you like
until you find someone that you're
comfortable with and you can do that in
no additional charge which is really
nice so if you'd like to join the over
four million people that have taken
charge of their mental health by talking
with an experienced betterhelp therapist
you can actually get 10% off by going to
better
heel.com softwhite underbelly or click
on the link in the video description box
below thank you for watching and now
back to the
video honestly I don't my favorite
celebr but the cool celebr party was
Miley tons of drugs tons of money she
$10,000 to spend the night with her she
want me 100k like not like 60k I was
doing like a photo shoot thing on time
and I'm BL so much money all in the
shoot I was up like maybe like 5K and
all drugs i r a stretch LMO it really
did
happen very confusing but she was doing
a shoot for paper magazine and I people
in her Inner Circle we don't talk about
my encounters cuz I've signed so many
ndas one thing about being insane is you
have to sign ndas cuz like Miley for
instance had a thing where like a video
of her smoking um Salvia in her bong and
at College went
um it went
viral probably the problem with your ear
could be that you're sticking your
fingers from your that's how I clear the
markk stop stop criticizing and do
something about it Mark I don't need the
critiques [__] I live a shitty life you
have a house a car and running water
running water
mark F any time water I find my water in
the
trash in the
garbage I have to [__] steal them
from other tents Mark how often are you
stealing all the time that's what I hear
all my clothes are SE that's my thing
out here I I start one I was just hot I
saw like
all these amazing towns like like
Fabrics in a sh C I was out here I never
done that before I just snatched one I
want I'm going to take it it's the weird
thing I've been doing
forever we yeah you good with the shave
we were fine thank you finally kind of
dream like kind oh what other medical
problems do you have your ear what else
ear fot money
sobriety sex so if youy I I have a guy
over kind bring guys up over here there
was something know to but like I get
messy so get me room with the hilt and
trackers so I can get a guy tonight your
vagina showing again it's not my vagina
it's my penis what
Mar she wanted to show off that [__]
dress that you gave me cuz the Fe trim
oh my god look the amount of tar on me
this is all
tar how do you feet get that dirty tar t
a r why are you walking in tar because
Mark Egyptians have more tar in their
skin at the time they the reason the
Egyptians tan and not turned into black
people it's kind of like Middle Eastern
like Olive looking people is because
they were covering them in tar when they
were torturing them that it end up
getting it so in it was like the most
popular form of torture for like 5,000
years that it end up getting embedded in
all their skin it's like it's like IM if
your fin use a spray a spray t for
breakfast lunch and dinner you know what
I mean but not for fun I don't got spray
TS like Lilo sorry
Lindsay that's Lilo anyway she fcking
Orange [__] it's not hard to [__]
get go either that like you're white go
made you white there's nothing a woman
wants to be around wants to [__]
globally that a white girl an American
white
girl a fetish girls a Asian girls Punk
girl French girl but a good old Missouri
perky tits
cheerleader about Carrie thank God that
when um what space when um Stephen King
cast Carrie cast space car he did
something very important for I think the
history of women in cinema which
something a woman didn't have to look
not just attractive but like the one
gang you know the weird girl you know
what I mean in a sitcom in a movie that
has like on liners became a
character it's very weird but it's
mainly men who make the most sensitive
Works about women like most women's wear
designers are M gay men straight men
doesn't matter I wonder where that comes
from is it like that they don't have the
empathy with a woman to like day-to-day
Basics mixed
with the way they want a woman to look
like are just the woman you want to [__]
or the woman you want to watch that
[__] we're try we're trying to make
too much of the equality or the
inequality of men and women who cares
when in fact they're very different you
have a
vagina being a man is very difficult
it's a lot of strenuous work no one
teaches you about emotions you can never
discuss them
you have to have kids or a dog or a
hobby you have to fit in unless you're
like an eccentric you know I mean when
you're a man fit women are very lucky
you can dress how they want and get away
with it or you look like a million bucks
today baby you don't see M like a red
lace full suit it just doesn't make
sense men have to wear a full suit in a
tie or a bow tie when it's [__] white
tie you know what I mean man go to work
he takes another one again my
baby song and you'd rather be a woman I
not rather be a woman yes a
woman
water it's good that you drink
water there H I love the taste of it she
so soothing about ice cold water she's
like oh my God
yeah you're a mess today Mark we're
going to go get me some clothes go to
the H Truck you're going to get me a
room with your credit card for one night
even it's not far from here on the phone
we should probably get a phone store
while we're
shopping rushing me Mark I just grab
some things I don't care I want to get
[__] I get I want to invite some ROM
Hawkeye over a bunch of hawkey over and
just [__] I [__] in a
year you want some guys to come over to
of course I been doing I was a kid what
did you say when I first was putting the
mic on you you want to you want to get a
dating oh because of well who was that
dating no you wanted to get like a Ao No
you want you wanted to get people to
date Rebecca Oh you mean grinder or the
PSA up so I
will ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
my name is
Rebeca I would like to discuss a problem
that not necessarily be a personal one
but I
feel will be greatly understood by the
general American society my name is REO
olon I need to get [__] so if you have
a cousin a friend some guy at work even
the janitor you know what I mean your
morning baresa who is Punky buff a
man no sensitive types no skinny wining
[__] Shawn Mendes Sean m i don't want
Justin
Bieber I don't mind a faka i a man a
real American red bu man to put his
Beefcake in me and F my body
up
unfortunately being in my line of work
up having nothing I can't afford a call
a guy or a stripper even to go to a club
to pick up a
Hawkeye and host them because I don't
have an apartment just go on and grind
and find a guy and do anything worse
than [__] toilet stalls out here so I
think if you yourself up you'd probably
have your pick of whoever you want [__]
you mark [__] you mark maybe if you
bathe me and Sh me love adoration father
I'll get you squeaky clean tomorrow
we'll come down here do to go to the H
ja shower there tomorrow we'll do
another talk we're going to do that
today we're going to go to today we're
going to get you clean we're going to go
to the hills and jackers today you're
going to get me a room get you clean get
you a w a b new clothes let's go let's
go right now I'm dying all right but I
think a doctor might be
might be the most
important I feel like if
my that [__] needs a
doctor that [__] needs a
doctor all
right no
[__] I pr
engagement Christin aular is man baby
shower at
both all right let's see if we can get
you fixed up just party like someone
else is doing something go to the
party book launch book
party no I mean run to interon right now
cuz he's going to get me a room I I'll
deliver whatever you need to thank you
Mark finally what out take care of you
Jus Christ you're worse than TT I'm way
worse than
TT Brooke
Candy where am I going again in content
no when you go
shopping Pretty Woman Pretty Woman Mike
pretty woman you a pretty woman
mik say B Pretty
Woman broke
candy love
jul
nasty makes no
sense
ah [__]
out
Pap
bankrupt why being sub you're not V
you're not vot why being sub for their
video I want how do I to the speaker to
the phone to the
[Music]
car
someone
Tokyo can we stop get a
[Music]
Bo H in the hot
one a
[Music]
hot right
here the hot
one music better than vogar like like so
severe Str but it's like
[Music]
Fierce my technique
my
technique how you know my V CU like it's
[__] to the
left [__] to the
[Music]
right it's
good
check
my all the way up
here
I we're trying to pay
for before EXC
me I've stayed at the of Home many times
um can I this one white you can yeah I
can actually well you can I'm uh Mark
Mark can you go in there and get me a
room no they're not going to let you in
Mark get yourself the room and I'll just
walk in no they're not going to let look
hard
Mark they're not going to let you stay
here is it cuz I'm gay gay too that [__]
you [__] nothing to do with you being
gay community [__] look at your feet
that's right what oh cuz
we're oh H you're a
ballet outside of Lobby make $100 a
month [__] I make $100 a minute with
this [__] really yeah I'm really famous
out here Rebecca ol on YouTube but
anyway not the point I stayed here
before Mark there's a shared right down
there around the corner we'll try that
one we won't get in there either I will
Mark can you try this is this exact
scenario is going to happen everywhere
great footage Mark let's go hey
slash
you want to try
again okay
[Music]
man
thank you for thank you for filming me
right now Mark really polite you have no
idea how much this hurts me I am a real
person [__] vagina [__] dick there's
no hotel that's going to take you to the
continenal sweetheart thank you Mark
thank you for having so much faith in me
I'm just telling you you could have
maneuvered that in a way where they
didn't do that but thank you Mark you
got me that Mo room how about going
there you took me to the one that was by
the
Armada the one that was kind of like
near
Town how out there big a
room Latino boys take me there mark
please if you just want to do the car
and throw me 100 bucks like I don't even
matter to you which I know I don't it's
fine you know then you can just do that
you it's what we're used when you're
when you're in this state you're not
going to get sh Hotel before Mar yeah
but you weren't in this crazy out of
your mind state they're not going to let
you in any hotel the Continental
probably won't even take you thank you
for just being so helpful about it I'm
just I'm sorry this offends you so much
you're not the one being called a clown
in your face some think I even belonged
in your
car cuz I'm wearing a wig and
heels can I put the phone back on
where's your phone I gave it to you all
right I have my
phone Classy Touch put your seat Bel
Stow
style can you just press the button Mar
there's a button you can press to do
what to turn the button off see it's
offu pull it you got to pull
it clean we got do sharpp and drive
exactly the curse of
cleop coming out before you can even get
in yeah I know was your dick sweetheart
they chase you away from the hotel
before you even because of my dick right
just not yours no it's because you're
out of your mind on drugs because of
your dick I'm sober Mark [__] you're not
sober I did not do any drugs last night
[__] well then you're out of your mic
some guy s me some fake crack I am out
of my mind Mark I thought that's what
you liked about me I thought that's what
made it so appealing oh Rebecca everyone
loves you well they love me cuz they get
me Mark these people out there know who
I am I'm like understood now like I I
can't tell you I know cuz you're in
Missouri where Chicago boy or whatever
I'm sorry I'm not a Boy Scout so [__] I
go to Starbucks they let me in
Starbucks I've been to the chatau
Mormont I let anyone in there have you
been to the chatau Mark I've been there
how many times have you been there Mark
I can't count dinner or have you stayed
there both how many times have you
stayed there mark not much I live here
exactly exactly
[__] exactly let's have some revenge
porn genten for
consideration
boom
crash Charlie x x h in it got it this
time got it this
time you sure don't want to take me to
that Motel Mark what motel the motel you
took me to I don't know the name of it
Mark when you took me to a motel
remember I'm getting hotels for about 20
people a week so like 5 miles from here
or four miles from here it was like you
know where the Armada in like that like
that kind of Career Town can't remember
the Continental oh yeah I remember yeah
can go there or no the Continental the
same problem is going to happen there
let's go to there was no problem there I
checked out early Mark [__] you
bought me the room it's a motel Mark I
remember it's just they won't let you in
they let me in they got me the room they
didn't that was that was in the evening
they didn't have rooms that night mark
it was worth
July Mark I don't know why your all your
recollection of me seems to be with my
insane
Behavior Mark yes I not very funny to me
to be honest with you I'm sorry that
with this sort of caliber of people you
interview because I talk quickly [__] I
don't know what so special about me
those people have stories to tell I'm
just a bum and a
dress sorry it's not like some hotot
drug
dealer hooked out prostitute named TIY
or charl
or
candy I'm know Candy the corner girl
chariss the C girl Amanda The Prostitute
I'm Rebecca Olson and I like things the
way I like them you should I don't
understand walking into a place and not
getting service this America freedom of
speech lgbc rights
[__]
[__] [__] [__] that's some
[__] I can pay Lord Michaels M
phone Mike ler he challenges me I can
pay got camera F you got the M you got
the cigarettes you got the root be the
ice cream the wigs the dresses and me I
mean Mark I think you well one day
learned the beautiful mistake of just
how much you have under racis made me
but don't worry about that you've caught
me at the worst point of my life at my
rock bottom I suppose you have earned
the right to know I'm going to be very
big in this town and you're going to
hate yourself about
it yal
yal you
know I don't be CR about it I had a lot
of people tell life for being rude to me
but I've should been my fair share of
human sacrifices so you
know check your your mail mark check
your
mailbox I can pay I can pay Mark ler he
challenges
I
so
name Mar turn
name
Ashley
Smashley and my name my name is Madame X
la la la la okay you
D la la
la
hey a [__] torch hey
babing
already
do you remember what happened yesterday
yeah we tried to get you a hotel room
yeah you insisted on the
Intercontinental which is
where presidents stay when they come
here I think I think Obama stayed there
once and you got kicked out the second
you approached the
door and then at the uh Bonaventure
which was your next
request they got physical with you and
tried to throw you
out and then even the Continental across
the street here the skid ow Hotel you I
just asked you just to be quiet just for
two minutes so I can get you a key to
the room and you couldn't do
that sorry meth is one hell of a
drug
or maybe was a lack of sleep did you
sleep I did yeah that's good that's why
you're a little more sane
today I suppose see I think what my
audience doesn't quite understand is how
insane you are sometimes CU I can't
really film you when you're like that
you're just insane you're out of your
mind this is Rebecca Eder not at your
very best but pretty close to it not
even
close
what happed to your nose what it's all
black I don't
know think I might be able to get your
room now
yeah if you don't
spend money on on
crystal what do you think of this
lifestyle what do you think of this
lifestyle that you keep
[Applause]
chasing I got a couple emails
yesterday that both of them might
pertain to you one is from an
immigration attorney who's willing to
help you out okay but I don't want to
put you on the phone with her even
unless you are cogent as can be cuz I
don't want I don't want to waste her
time
[Music]
yeah you think you're capable of
communicating intelligently with
somebody I definitely am maybe tomorrow
if you get you want a hotel tonight that
might help yeah yeah you get your voice
back H you get your voice back
definitely
and the other one is from a a rehab in
Pasadena that is looking for
people from my Channel that I can
recommend can you even do a group rehab
program I don't see you as a group
person but maybe you
are I mean I guess let me let me
consider that I'm sorry let me consider
that yeah you can you think about that
one if you're not ready you're not ready
I get
that I know this lawyer who could help
me out with my case that's definitely
something I want to
pursue okay well it's up to you to kind
of get into a state
of soberness or whatever you want to
call it
Clarity that you can communicate with
her and tell her what's going on with
your
case I suppose or your situation yeah
there's no case yet
but I'm glad you survived the
night
yeah I thought
something what happened to the dress I
got you I know I'm still wearing it
you're still wearing it yeah good
what do you need most a night of
sleep no just honestly like again like I
keep saying just to reintegrate into
society or
just
I know I feel like I've been seeing on
my worst
so only my best can come if without Mak
sense yeah no when you when you are semi
sober at least or sober I can tell you
Rebecca you're going to have a ton of
people that want to be your
friend but when you were like you were
yesterday you're
impossible I care a lot about you and I
I just wanted to hit you yesterday you
were
insane I left you on the curb I left you
on the sidewalk here just without any
money I didn't even want to give you
money cuz I knew what you're going to
spend it on and I drove
away I hate doing that to you but
yesterday you were so
insane that I I didn't want to give you
money for more
meth how many hours did you sleep H I
know I about 20 huh about 20 probably
not at all I
know what do you need other than
integrating into society what do you
need right now
immediately I don't think more meth is
going to be
helpful especially with your immigration
situation
it's not that it's just
like there are so many people out there
again who seem
to get me you know what I mean
mhm I'd just rather be around those
sorts of
people but where do these people know
you from just from the streets or from
my Channel or from
where just in general
I but they recognize
you
yeah and because the Rebecca that people
find uh endearing or whatever word you
want to
use is the Rebecca who
is somewhat
cogent the the more the more sober you
are the more likable you
are but when you're going to get high
you're just going to repel these people
that you
attracted I can guarantee that you're
insane when you're high or when when
you're lacking a week of
sleep I don't know even me who who
really wants to help you and we'll bend
over backwards and drive downtown just
to connect with you yeah I just wanted
to just throw you in the in the dumpster
yesterday you were
so impossible to deal with
I'm kicking myself that I didn't
document the whole thing but I got bits
and pieces that I can show people what
I'm talking
about cuz when you're when you're less
High than you were yesterday you're
you're
incredibly
likable
yes what can I do for you right now you
want what can I do for you right now you
want to get a
room you want to get clothes you want to
get what do you want to get yeah gu bits
of both
definitely want to got lawyer any now
well if you get get a good night of
sleep try not to get high tomorrow I'll
I'll meet with you and and we'll we'll
call the lawyer
okay we'll see if we can help your your
situation
yeah cuz that that's important you want
to stay in this country I do definitely
well this the key might be putting down
the Pookie pipe for a
day if you can res if you can somehow do
that
I'll give you money to eat I'll give you
money to buy clothes or wigs even if you
want but I'll get you a room but the you
should take a shower for sure
definitely definitely definitely take a
shower and uh and then I'll put you on
the phone and we'll see we can help you
with your immigration situation
okay she seemed opt optimistic that they
can help you out that's
perfect just don't get
hi all right let's get you
some clothes and maybe even some
food
[Music]
for